bonjour monsieur vous êtes poursuivi
pour 11 viols aggravés
dont 7 suivi de meurtre avec
préméditation c'est à dire assassinat
vous encourez la peine de réclusion à
perpétuité le lycée franquemagne notre
nouveau cinquième deux groupes
tu vas commencer par te fade et les
dossiers en cours du groupe c'est la
tradition en 36
et le dossier parce que le scarface elle
a été violée pendant des heures après il
l'a torturé il a joué avec elle ça c'est
la récompense
il ya un progrès qu'ont dressé j'y suis
allé et c'est de garder un peu de
distance signale t on lire sur ses
débuts en tant que sur des suspects y
colle pas pour moi il ya quelque chose
qui nous fait sortir 28 ans violée puis
égorgée
23 ans je voulais que ce soit en vue la
réalité c'est qu'il ya des liens
possible mais pas certain si tu tues
s'arrête présent recommence on travaille
mal tous ont travaillé mais enfin sophie
violé et égorgé
si j'ai une vie compliquée de merde
c'est ça quand je te parle
les analyses sont tombés c'est le même
homme
je veux qu'on lance un avis de recherche
sur les sept homicides c'est une course
contre la montre messieurs il faut qu'on
fasse vite
le code génétique a été baptisé est ce
qu'à un serial killer numéro un c'est le
premier tueur en série dont on à
l'empreinte génétique heures
vous avez fait un travail impressionnant
plus juste celui qui a traqué pendant
sept ans moi je suis celle qui tracte
l'homme derrière le monstre
l'adena paris
il s'appelle qui georges pourquoi tu as
tué qui